in los angeles greer garson presents the  famous Oscar to Jennifer Jones star of  the song of Bernadette this is the 16th  annual award by the Academy of Motion  Picture Arts and Sciences George Murphy  presents the coveted little man - Paul  Lucas for his outstanding performance in  watch on the ride  Theresa right makes the award to Katina  packs a new for her excellent supporting  role in For Whom the Bell Tolls for Best  Supporting Actor  Donald crisp hands it to Charles Coburn  in the more the merrier  Universal led the color division with  Phantom of the Opera Jack Benny sponsors  another best to Jack Warner for  producing Casablanca